[Music]
hello and welcome to the dead stream my
name is Susie and I will be your host in
this episode and I am joined this
afternoon by my co-host the fluff of
nightmares lady White's rabbit hey
everybody welcome we are also joined
tonight by the third voice of death
mortis media hey guys you're listening
to episode 3 of the dead stream so
there's this movie that came out so this
month I think it was called it have you
guys heard about it yeah I think it's a
real underground film yeah I mean I was
thinking about maybe talking about it
but I don't know this isn't really a
movie podcast mm hmm hmm do you think
they want to hear anything about it we
could just skip to our kinder surprise
egg horror stories what do you guys
think I think all right so it's what did
you guys like about it what did you guys
dislike about it well I I really liked
the fact that it captured an eighties
feel of a film well that for me at least
and I loved the way they I just I just
loved everything about it the way it was
made it wasn't just about horror it was
a horror film that had a lot of things
going on and it wasn't just we're trying
to scare you it was about a story that
had horror in it and that's why I liked
it was a lot more innovative than so
many horror films that have come out
recently just so much I'm sure that I
would have that 80s nostalgia had I not
been born in the 90s
- well one thing that I think it did
really well which pun intended by the
way um I think it kind of relates to
what you were saying about the nostalgia
though but just the child actors were
really good and they just did a really
good job of capturing the essence of
being a kid during the summer exactly
rabbit what was your favorite part about
the movie I am a rabid Tim Curry fan so
of course I was judging and looking for
Penny wises performance and I thought it
was pretty damn good I mean he I don't
know if it was on purpose but his voice
just sounded like it was a no Maj that's
him curry and how he played - penny wise
and it's impressive to make me happy
about somebody remaking a Tim Curry
performance is really difficult to do so
well done I'll get I'll reply to that in
a second there's this comment in the
chat Casey Johnson George II shouldn't
have been outside what does that mean
what does that mean Casey Johnson I I
don't understand so on on the voice I
think that Bill crcr did a very good job
acting as many wise the voice I would
have to say that I liked Tim Curry's a
lot better I feel like with the with the
new one he was really trying too hard to
make it creepy like you can just hear
him putting boohoo like so much effort
into every syllable and making it
high-pitched and stuff and oh yeah I
really I really preferred the voice of
the Tim Curry Pennywise what are your
thoughts Martin mm-hmm it's a hard one I
really liked both but yeah I think Tim
Curry's is a bit hard to be is the
classic oh well of course but um but no
I thought his performance regardless was
was still pretty good but I do agree his
voice was a bit forced at times like at
the very start especially when you meet
the character yeah you know I initially
had that feeling but you know it kind of
grows on you until the end of the film
but okay Casey Johnson replied she was
saying like who lets their kid play
outside in the rain
the 80s yeah they say I wasn't lazy but
I think it has something to do with the
time period parents yeah I can actually
do a pretty good Tim Curry penny wise
voice oh let's hear I actually did it
for a brief moment in the niebolt house
video that I did but hiya Georgie don't
you wanna know beep-beep Richie that's
pretty good that's pretty good I'll
probably pull that one out again for a
future video one of the other things
that I liked was they gave Stan Lee's
character a lot more attention in the
miniseries he kind of got the short end
of the stick compared to everybody and I
like how they gave him a backstory I
like how they gave him like his own fear
because from what I recall from the mini
series is he didn't really have like he
saw something but we didn't know what it
was that like really scarred him which
is cool but I like how they give him
like his own thing to be afraid of and
they had the whole the whole character
arc with his Bar Mitzvah what did you
guys think of that monster from the from
the temple I thought it was pretty
creepy in all honesty that the painting
the painting lady yeah it was that was
really I mean I really like the way they
did it and it was really creepy how was
I stretchy and disproportionate I think
I think was quite well done what about
you
oh yeah I definitely think it was a kind
of a theme throughout the whole movie
though is they they wanted to go much
creepier with it and they succeeded
which kept my attention much more of it
they they can get away with a lot being
it wasn't a TV series anymore yeah
that's the one that's one of the things
that I really liked about it they've
established a much darker tone right
away link right from that opening scene
you could tell this is gonna be a much
darker version of it oh yeah
as far as the the lady with the flute
from the painting
I guess a lot of people are saying that
it was very similar to the monster from
mama which is also directed by the same
director oh I thought that was kind of
interesting huh very cool thoughts on
the music I really like the music my
favorite part it was so well done I've
listened to the soundtrack and listen to
some of news covers I I really go into
it I mean I really like music anyway but
it really had me going about listening
after the film it just all blended so
well together
the soundtrack overall for me I would
have to say overall I liked it better
than the one from the mini series
however yeah the Pennywise theme I don't
think that they're gonna beat the one
from the mini series like the one that
plays in the library and at the end of
the mini series that to me is just so
creepy oh yeah
which which one did you think was
scarier like I said I thought the new
one was scarier because they they pushed
the boundaries of what they could do
when it wasn't limited by a TV series
and they definitely upped the creep
factor and there's a lot of there's a
few jump scares in there I think is kind
of cheap but you know it's it works
well I I think I agree with rabbit-like
especially the opening scene you just
it's just so much more visual didn't he
just really hoped you in from the start
at least that would that was Michael I
think this one was definitely a lot more
graphic but I would say like I would say
I was more scared by the original and I
think it took me a few days after
watching it and just thinking about it
to decide why but I think it's because
the original Pennywise like they really
tied it into the whole thing where it
was connected to the sewers and
everytime Pennywise appeared it was near
a drain and I remember as a kid watching
that and like if I went up to go to the
shower by myself like I would have this
thought in the back of my head that
Pennywise could be in there
because like it made that association
that it was connected to the drain
whereas in this one it was kind of just
less connected to the drain and more
just kind of roaming throughout Derry I
want to give a quick shout out to oh s
teamaker in the chat he is the composer
of the song that you heard for the intro
and the song that you will hear in the
outro he's a fantastic composer be sure
to go check out his channel he's amazing
but as I was saying what was I saying he
was thinking about the dreams and how he
was scared yeah and then the other thing
with this one is they I think they tried
a little bit hard to make Pennywise
creepy especially like with some of the
animations that they did with the visual
effects and having him like distort his
body and stuff some of them were really
cool I liked the the thing where it was
stabilized to his head and he was
dancing a lot oh yeah
just the idea of Pennywise is inherently
creepy and you don't need to try that
hard to make it scary in my opinion so
yeah I feel like my my view on it is
slightly skewed because I actually
didn't see it for the first time until
after I fell in love with Tim Curry and
I had to look up everything he's been in
so I didn't ever find
Pennywise scary when I saw it originally
because I loved the actor and I would
like be friends with him if he walked up
to me in real life that's but I never
saw it when I was a kid so I was never
like scared of clowns as a kid because
it was never traumatizing to me so what
do so I oh I probably first saw it like
probably three years ago or so because I
just I never had it on TV as a kid and
my parents didn't watch horror or
anything so I just never was interested
because I never understood why everybody
was afraid of clowns and I'm like oh
it's because of this movement they also
when they were kids but I never did yeah
I mean it does seem like there's a
faction of people now who just hate them
in E series and I think I think you do
kind of have to see it as a kid in order
for it to really affect you right right
right
I still like it I like both versions
mm-hm
what about you more when did you first
it things I'm in the same boat as rabbit
my parents were really into horror so
yeah by the time I saw it you know
wasn't that that's scary so you saw a
family recently yeah a fairly recently
like I had watched oh good no no I'm
just saying I had to watch it you know
quite recently just so that I had some
context before I saw the newsroom all
right right cuz you hadn't seen it like
a couple dead streams ago or something
yeah yeah so you saw it so I most
recently yeah the one thing this is
probably my biggest dislike about it the
fact that they made Beverly
like a damsel in distress in distress
the fact that she is captured by penny
wise and they have to go save her
because yeah in the book and I believe
in the miniseries as well she is she's
like one of the guys and part of how the
offbeat penny wise is she's she gets
like a silver a piece of silver that she
uses the slingshot to shoot at him and
she's like the best shot out of any of
them with the slingshot mm-hmm so it was
kind of disappointing that they just had
her get captured and she's not really a
big part of the fight yeah I hope in the
continuation when when she's older I do
hope they change that because you're
absolutely right yeah yeah so here are
the the things that I was wondering
about for the next part and I'm
interested to see like what they're
gonna do with this so it seems like in
this one when they're climbing in the
well to go down into the sewer
that's like Henry Bowers falls down that
and it's it looks like at the bottomless
pit so I'm wondering like does he die
right there because if he does then
that's gonna drastically change part two
so I guess we'll never we won't know
until then yeah and then there was a lot
of stuff that see that could possibly
affect the next part so for example
Beverly's dad
he passes away like sometime in between
but does he pass away at the end like
during this movie is that why she was
moving - yeah I'm pretty sure it was
because you know he said yeah I'm going
with my aunt so I can get all this stuff
I can't remember the exact line but um I
think it you know was pretty explicit
they was because that dad was dead well
I mean it could be because he was dead
it could be because he was like I'll
have to wait and see you know what it
comes out the next part yeah I'm not
sure and I'm not entirely sure that
they've even shot it yet because I
remember reading something that said
like because this movie did very well
I'm looking at the chat with because
this one did very well then they would
have an expanded budget for the next one
because I guess this one didn't have a
huge budget yeah speaking of which what
did you guys think of the visual effects
no thoughts hmm I mean the one that
stuck out to me as a little bit cheesy
was when they were in the garage doing
the the slide show it comes out of the
screen but yeah like maybe that was
supposed to be a little bit cheesy
because it's like he's coming out of a
2d image but that one was the only one
that really bothered me I heard a lot of
complaints about the VFX but I didn't
really mind them for the most part and
like I said I don't remember thinking
throughout the whole movie like this is
corny like it looked pretty alright to
me like I said I think of the the
dancing scene where the head was
stabilized was really cool have you guys
seen any of the memes that have come out
of that I was just gonna say it's a
hilarious memes do I actually have seen
any
I keep seeing the Summa memes but yeah
they can I do one someone put up like
this this video where they put various
different songs instead of the music
that plays there so they put me like
they put a like catch me outside girl
and the latest means oh what is
happening in the chat spammer well we
might want to turn on the slow chat if
that becomes a problem so the other
thing that I didn't really like about it
was the fact that Mike kind of got
shortchanged they didn't really expand
on his relationship with Bill and they
didn't really expand on his backstory in
the original he has this relationship
with his father and his father just kind
of like teaching him how to deal with
racism and dairy and stuff and then this
one his parents aren't even alive yeah
and it's like a grandfather or something
yes his greatest grandfather cuz his
parents died in the fire
so I hope that this that that doesn't
have a negative effect on the next part
where he has where it kind of highlights
his his close relationship with Bill he
was more like an extra in this one you
know apart from the scene at the end he
was I thought what he was given so
little attention throughout the whole
thing yeah he did still have kind of his
rivalry with Henry Bowers yeah but I
mean by after he threw him down the well
that was kind of it yeah anyhow and he
hardly had any lines anyway it was it
was a bit of a shame I think you're
right
I mean like I said maybe in maybe in the
second part he'll he'll be a bigger role
like Beverly but laughter wait and see I
wouldn't be surprised to see the second
part be even a little bit longer I think
this one was pretty good in terms of
pacing I think the scares were a little
bit too close there was a time issue um
but I think there wasn't really like any
dead air like I wasn't bored during any
of it and I wouldn't have minded seeing
it longer so yeah maybe they'll just go
crazy with the next one maybe they
released the extended version right any
other thought it wasn't that much you
know was that yeah I I remember actually
openly laughing at the first one and not
so much at this one there were a lot of
laughs in my theater yeah especially uh
like the banter between Richie and Eddie
oh yeah that that stuff was good how
sassy Eddie he was I loved it
what do you guys just in general not
talking about it necessarily but what do
you think about humor in horror I think
it's pretty useful especially if it's
kind of an uncomfortable or it helps
break up some of that uncomfortableness
more I think it really depends how it's
done in the context I mean you need to
know how to write it in in order to get
away with it you can't just throw it in
and how has it Leo it just sucks yeah
sure
if they try to I've really only seen one
movie that combines humor and horror in
the same moment and done a good job of
it and that would be the visit there
were parts that were like disturbing but
also funny at the same time I usually
don't like that kind of thing though but
if you have humorous parts pasted nicely
throughout the horror so when you're
when you're not in a horror scene it
kind of lowers your your guard goes down
I think that's a really good tactic yeah
but I think I'd like to see more more
things that more more films that try and
play on both elements so maybe you don't
have to go and watch what you say to
visit yeah maybe Jay Rodriguez in the
chat says Georgie's death was way too
much CGI so I think it definitely did
bother
quite a few people which is weird
because I do visual effects from time to
time and it didn't bother me a whole lot
but I guess part of the fact I like it's
a clown that you're doing CGI on like a
clown is supposed to be kind of
animating so that just helps make it
okay for me yeah
fan Theory from harry reid's what if
Pennywise is actually a sad clown and
everyone in the town signed a suicide
pact with him during his depression and
he's come to help them follow through I
would a good guy
so any other thoughts on the movie
before I move on I heard that it
surpassed the Exorcist box-office funds
is that right oh yeah and I think that's
gonna be great for the horror community
in general uh-huh especially holy crap
we've been going through with trying to
get advertisers and stuff yeah like just
seeing a hugely successful r-rated
horror movie people are gonna want to
advertise on that people are gonna want
to take chances on other horror content
as well right on I think it's a good
segue great segue into the news or
should we segue into our don't hug me
i'm scared discussion whatever you wanna
do by the way all right so just so we
can so we can stay organized so last
time mark watched the first two episodes
of don't hug me I'm scared this time he
finished the rest of the series so what
are your immediate reactions mark I have
no idea what's going on and I really
want answers and there were just so many
questions every episode added about five
new questions it's like what is the
meaning of July 19th is it June or July
June June 19th yes you know
it's like the red one goes into the
office it's just so much going on and I
just I just don't understand I just
don't understand
shout out to West Dakota he just jammed
in with two dollars in the super chat
and said this should help alleviate your
D monetization West Dakota we will thank
you we'll split the dollars between the
three of us and hopefully we can get by
for the next month thank you thank you
so what was your biggest question about
don't hug me
I suppose it well biggest question is I
want to know everything biggest question
today what did you guys even make me
watch came out when he was in the last
episode when he was in the computer room
and he pulled the plug how he woke up
and everything was changing it was the
next day I mean was it all a dream was I
don't even know we're gonna have more
watch and explanation video that we both
really like so hopefully next month
there will be a lot less questions well
do you want to give your interpretation
on that rabbit from what I when I saw I
kind of go with the the explanation
video I saw there's a huge theme that
surrounds the entire series and that
computer room is kind of just it all
coming together there in the end I don't
know if I want to give away too much
before you watch the video yourself but
it's it's a big conclusion once you
understand everything else that's going
on okay I see I see you don't hug me I'm
scared as like a show within the show so
when he when he pops out of that and he
goes back to the real world if he's
doing just that he's going like from
this fantasy thing where he
just like have fun and goof off with his
friends and sing these songs and it's
like he's snapping back to reality and
so like he leaves the show he has to go
gets a traditional job so so it's a show
within a show that's I think up to
interpretation yeah yeah yeah and then
feel free to make your own
interpretations of it because even the
the creators were like everybody's right
because the whole point is was we're not
going to stop you from making your own
theories I just alright I've got an
answer for Kim Du Bois so Kim what is
don't hug me don't hug me I'm scared is
a very interesting YouTube well it's six
YouTube videos short videos just type in
don't help me I'm scared they have tens
of millions of views I think the first
one is about 41 million views so a lot
of people have seen it I recommend after
this stream you go check it out and
we'll talk about an extreme because it's
and obviously watch what's the analysis
because I want to know and it would be a
great great talk cuz I'm so confused
you'll be as confused as I am so just
just wait and sing I would say it's my
favorite web series like debatably I
would say that video game high school is
my favorite because that has several
seasons and it has more of a like a
grounded story but I've watched don't
hug me i'm scared probably like 50 times
by now and i'm a video game high school
maybe twice all the way through but go
ahead in the chat and chime in with your
interpretations of the series and we'll
read some of them out on the show so
should we jump into the news then let's
go for it
more do you want to talk about the first
news item so new to YouTube's new layout
slash logo should we be upset that they
are working on
this and not the sub box issues and
monetization issues and is this trying
to change their image in response to all
the negative feedback that they got you
know a few months ago with the whole
PewDiePie thing and then how everyone
got that he wanted to give everyone got
D monetize is this a way to kind of
rebrand themselves to show that they're
new and they're you know they're the new
YouTube with new rules that are much
stricter and everyone else mostly the
horror community is that is that I
suppose that's the question yeah that's
what bright red means right that's the
universal symbol first strict but I
would say that like the timing of it I
would say that they are trying to just
like change up their image and show that
they are doing something however I don't
think we have to be upset that they came
out with a new layout instead of working
on the current issues that they have
because I think and I don't know this
for a fact but I get the feeling that
it's a different team that works on the
different team of engineers works on the
design of the website as opposed to like
the subscription feature and the
monetization feature I know for a fact
that the subscription feature has like
its own team of energy engineers so I
imagine the the layout of YouTube is
just like a totally different team
entirely I'm imagining that they've been
working on that change for a while
they've been moving towards material
design in all of the Google products so
it makes sense that they would do that
update what are your thoughts on that
rabbit yeah I didn't think honestly too
deeply was just like okay so they've
added new features and it looks a little
bit different
I mean it's to me it's the same as like
when Facebook changes up their style
nothing really gets any better as far as
issues on the website but it just looks
a little different I suppose and maybe
they're just trying to keep it looking
fresh so that it's you know it still
looked like somebody's something behind
the scenes but I don't think it's I
don't think it's anything to offend us
personally I just like you said I think
it's a different team working on that
whole part of it
do you like the new the new layout I
personally like the dark theme that's
something that I actually had on YouTube
before they changed it I had like a
chrome addition to let me have a dark
theme yes I mean so that's all I really
did with it yeah and I I like that they
give you access to all of the different
menus in the drop-down oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I like dog thing the moment I found
out about it it was switched on it's
pretty good
the new app doesn't let you access
people's contact info and it also takes
two clicks to get to the video manager
but like none of those things are really
the end of the world for me but to win
it some things on your profile you have
used to revert back to the old mode to
change it rabbit do you want to talk
about hell freezer be that rabbit well I
guess we have lost lady white rabbit
unfortunately but our next news item is
the YouTube narrator hell freezer is
taking a break apparently he's had some
health issues do you did you find out
anything about that more no I couldn't
find out any more but I you know if any
of you guys in the stream saw his video
pretty sure but just said that he was
having some health problems and that he
would have to take a break and oh it's
back hey rabbit and yes I read that no
it's alright but I didn't I didn't
actually and I think he's posted
no he hasn't posted since then so I
didn't have serious is I hope he's all
right rabbit I'm so glad you're back
because losing health freezer and not
losing you would have just been too much
but we do wish him the best of luck in
his recovery whatever it may be
yeah so darkness prevails posted this
tweet apparently he's been taking some
heat lately for the way that he
pronounces the word
faster in one of his videos he got a
bunch of hey yes because I guess it
sounded like he was saying pasture so
hey guys ever had something happen like
that where you you do a narration and
you get a bunch of backlash because of
the pronunciation of something hell yes
hell yeah I I was reading a story one of
them was this state park it's a big part
in America I can't even remember the
name now but was it a mountain it was it
was the name of the place and I
pronounced it phonetically as she do but
it was actually a native I think was a
Native American way of saying it and
everyone said oh you're saying it wrong
you're saying it wrong you should look
things up before you narrate and I mean
yeah I mean you can't look up every word
and think I wonder if I'm pronouncing it
correctly but but still you know I learn
I'm gonna have to try and remember the
word but it was a pretty it was a pretty
important place I guess um so in the
chat I noticed West Dakota say one of
you said something that set Alexa off on
my echo thanks so I've always wanted to
try this like during a live stream or
something so hey Siri call 9-1-1 do it
well I don't know I guess I guess we'll
never find out if if we just triggered
everybody who's watching this dream
[Laughter]
sweet I can imagine the best yeah see
the numbers are dropping do you want to
oh yeah so my experience with
pronunciation thing so I did an episode
of all day and I creepypasta it was
creepy kids drawings and I pronounced
the word
crayon and in the middle in the Midwest
most people just pronounce it cran and I
got all these comments say like Kranz
like see and they're spelling at CRA AMS
and I couldn't figure out why it's
actually pronounced crayon yeah
have you had any instances like that
rabbit the only one I can think of as I
I don't I still don't know if I'm
pronouncing your right Edinboro I think
I pronounced it Edinboro and people were
freaking out in the comments about it it
sounds like guys hold them down first of
all I I'm in America so I don't say it
at all and second of all it's just a
pronunciation why does it have to ruin a
story for you it was it was Yosemite and
I pronounced it you're out okay
let's understand why oh I see your mic
yours might like turn like yeah I guess
here it's like the most well known state
park probably American know it learn to
pronounce Yosemite and then I heard a
rock video like the next week I'm gonna
give a shout-out to Thomasina Warrington
who tweeted at me during the dead stream
I have my Twitter mentions up during the
dead stream so if you guys tweet at me
then you may or may not get a shout out
so next item I find really funny do you
want to read that one rabbit
I was killer orange cat yeah so is that
were on here kill orange cat changed a
fan on a validity validity of haunted it
doll Annabelle let's see what this tweet
is here
so I gotta open it up here okay it says
uh I called an NIC someone called me out
on it and dared me to go to the museum
and taunt her you cut up and she said I
called Annabelle fake at the beginning
oh sorry
yeah I can't tell when I cut out someone
called me on it and dared me to go to
the museum and taunter my response pay
for the trip and I'll do one more than
that
I'll tell Annabelle to go [ __ ] off and
give hi and give five fat guys to moon
er I have no issue taunting a doll
brought bought by two con artists with a
made-up backstory there's zero evidence
anyone who who taunted her has was hurt
in any way he'll give me a brick and
I'll set her free
you know what she'll do nothing just sit
there because she's a doll that's that's
just so funny to me what do you guys
think about the paranormal I mean I I
would honestly love to see evidence of
paranormal activity but I've never seen
or experienced it in my life so
currently I am a skeptic I mean I read
about 20 20 30 para normal stories a
week heard so many people I know
personally in England say things like ah
you know I this happened to me and it
was really strange or I saw something
and I couldn't explain it like this suck
this stump up this one person I met just
we were talking I hadn't said anything
I haven't even started my channel by
then and we were just chatting and she
came out she said yeah my uncle because
we're talking about country roads cuz I
live I used to live out in the
countryside and she said yeah my my
uncle was on striving out the country
road and it wasn't foggy or anything and
any was as he was coming over like like
a little came he came from a dip and
then he came up again and he saw
something that looked an awful thing
like fog in the distance and then as he
approached he flipped his lights on and
he saw and it was a guy with only
the upper half of his body and I he
stopped the car and ran out to see what
was there and there was nothing in the
property to tell him drove away hmm
and I mean I mean I don't know like
there's so many people who always
claimed always say they see something
that something's happened could everyone
be lying to me that's that's what I
asked us I've never seen anything but I
would love to see something but just to
have that proof of myself but I haven't
seen anything so I can't really say
anything but I'd love to think that
there is more out there I haven't seen
anything I love the idea that that could
exist but I really don't believe that it
does I think a lot of people are in the
same boat and they want to see it so
badly that they kind of think that they
do see something yeah I don't think
people are lying to you I just think
maybe they thought they all saw it and
it's just popular belief I think that's
scary is the paranormal that just the
fact that your mind can force you to do
something oh yeah like the whole Bloody
Mary thing apparently the the reason
that that works on people is because
they believe so badly that they are
going to see Bloody Mary that that like
they literally do see it and that's
terrifying to me as well okay if you
think about it that's even scarier
because then it's like you're the only
one who can see it exactly unless you
convince a whole group of people they
saw it yeah which I'm sure that's
happened in the past as well okay but
going back to the Annabelle thing there
is a channel called possessed by horror
who did a really good video basically
exposing the Warren couple the
paranormal investigators from those
movies that like the real life the real
life versions I'm talking about she went
through like case by case and exposed
like how they twisted the facts and
they're basically just entertainers very
good video the channels called possessed
by or
sounds quite interesting so just one
milestone on this episode the dark piano
composer mu G recently hit 200,000
subscribers so he's an incredibly dude
that's 11 years yeah he's a pioneer just
a legend really well I actually have
some news I hit 40 K like 10 min like 20
years before the spring started oh wow
congratulations guys I was looking at
your sub count like earlier today when I
was putting the links in the description
and stuff and I was like aha 39
something it looks like he's not gonna
make it before the net stream of to give
him the 40k shoutout next time thank you
but yet I'm Miyagi
I don't personally use his music and my
stuff but I love listening to his music
and the only reason that I don't use it
is because like he's so popular and so
many times his music that like I want my
stuff to feel fresh yeah
he's popular because I mean he's one of
the very few people who are giving his
music for free which is just an
incredible gesture I mean he knows that
must just can't afford to buy music so
he's giving us his is well-known music I
mean it's that's awesome to me yeah
such a kind heart such a lovely thing to
do I think I think now we're starting to
see a lot more people who put up their
music royalty-free
but I'm surprised that that didn't catch
on sooner because if you think about
it's like the the artists who do give
their music by royalty free there are a
few who are really popular and you just
hear those songs over and over again
yeah it wouldn't be as popular as they
were if they didn't do that exactly it's
a good way to get your music out there I
mean you're not paying us and you don't
have to because we want your
music yeah I mean like all the pop [ __ ]
some family members follow popular blogs
channels and they all use exactly the
same track so whoever wrote but must be
doing you know it's probably well also
there's like a genre that's like a genre
of music that's associated with
mainstream vlogs like they all have to
be the same you know what I mean like
it's always this like high-energy
electronic poppy kind of music mm-hmm so
last news item for today dutchess dark
announced that she's going to be
quitting YouTube after Halloween that's
right yeah I had a chat with her and she
she's gonna be migrating over the
patreon seeing how that goes because she
she expressed that she didn't feel
valued I think she said you know you
wouldn't expect you know receive a
painting for free or you know for very
little so you know she feels like she's
making quality content which she used
and she's getting you know next to
nothing back and she's thought well I'm
fighting a losing battle I'm gonna try
somewhere else and you know I respect
that you know you've got to stand up
yourself and if it's not working out you
have to do what's best for you
mmm-hmm you just did a collab with her
recently right yeah yeah we've done a
few good this place really it was more
like things we've done before but just
to give her a little feature hmm um I
don't know how I feel about completely
migrating to patreon because like I wish
her all the best but I feel like if you
do that then you're not gonna have
really a chance to grow any bigger than
you are
yeah I mean of course that's a risk but
I think she's also gonna be posting
somewhere else I can't remember where
maybe it's Vic me maybe it's somewhere
else but she she she's definitely gonna
keep making for an audience letting her
audience know I think it's gonna be like
a slow migration process to see who who
follows sort of the I don't even think
she's gonna I think she might even put
up a video
patron free and bacon donate if they
want - I'm not entirely sure I didn't
ask it though
I always thought that would be funny
just opening a patreon and like having
everything you released be free just
using it as a distribution platform so I
was going to cut the news off there for
time but I noticed STR radio yeah is the
chat right now
so hey hello one of our news items was
that there's now SC RM radio so I guess
they started this website in June and
it's a it's a horror internet radio
channel and it runs 24/7 and features
some of your favorite narrators that's
awesome it's so good do you guys have
the page up yeah so they have anti
creeps
DJ mistress McCobb doctor creepin van
pasta oh that's another speaking of
pronunciation mmhmm McCobb macabre a
macabre the Cobb yeah
Kelis t I'm probably pronouncing all
these rooms de and mr. creepypasta yeah
several others I think that's looking
really good it's mr. creepy paster I
think it's an interesting concept though
taking a more traditional radio approach
and getting narrators from the YouTube
community yeah I think it's really cool
it's kind of like old-timey radio how
they used to entertain people with
stories on the radio it's taking it back
to that whole era and that's awesome
because it's also giving narrators
another place to go thank you
yes thanks had you guys heard of it
before before right now Illness Nami
I think I'd heard him mentioned by mr.
creepypasta but I was about it so creepy
bathroom for
I've been at it for a few months but I
just found about it out about it
recently and thought it would be a whole
thing to share all rights so that that
Kinder Surprise egg horse story we may
have to say for last for next time but
we do have a Kinder Surprise egg
commercial creepy egg commercial thing
should get you guys excited about it
so you guys pumped up for the creepy can
do surprise egg horror story that we are
gonna share so we're gonna play that
right now what is that Humpty Dumpty I
was talking about what was in the egg oh
that's the toy the toys look like
they're inside that little egg oh okay
that's why America has banned the that
the kinder well for some reason I
imagined it as like you just opened the
egg and the toys directly in there oh no
so you gotta sometimes play with the
other yeah yeah yeah it's like a Russian
nesting can drag imeem I think part of
what makes this really creepy is just
the way that the lips match up to the
sounds that are actually coming out is
like so distorted adding to this
nightmare fuel the legs are really
disturbing too like a why does an egg
have legs and why are they at like such
a broken maimed angle like that
and he's dead don't you guys find it
weird that there's an egg eating an egg
isn't that sort of like cannibalistic
already yeah I believe so yeah so that
was beyond disturbing if you guys have
any creepy commercials or anything that
we might be able to watch on the dead
stream then hit us up in the comments or
the chat and if you guys are listening
on iTunes or Google Play right now
remember you can tune in on C's world to
see the Dead stream live and just watch
those videos with us I love the reaction
from the chat right now oh yes
welcome to forum commercials I think
that might have actually had in England
which is well I mean it must have right
yeah because it was a British guy at the
end sir and they didn't have him in
America so it must have been Englander
stupid okay english-speaking country
yeah I think it was the UK gosh and yeah
great so we also have an audio story
actually how long is this see it's time
for this we've been going for about 50
minutes so far okay so yeah this is only
9 minutes we could do it girls go oh
jeez
[Music]
all right I had to close up Arabica cuz
it uh it created a continuous loop oh so
I'm gonna bring that back don't close me
not you the program rabbit do you guys
have rabbit you want to tell them about
the announcements that you made on your
channel while I get that up oh yes I
made a Halloween update video on Friday
for those of you haven't checked it out
last year I did the the longest story
I've ever recorded which is Piroska it's
two and a half hours long and since then
the author yeah I was the nightmare
since then the author made a sequel or a
continuation or part five or whatever
you want to call it named it bar Oscar V
or Baraka five and I've been asked to do
that by me people and I am currently
almost done recording it and I will have
it up the Monday before a Halloween for
my special and my channels anniversary
so and that is thank you it's uh it's
even longer so it's going to be a good
time just no editing how long is the raw
audio so far let me see here I'm about
five chapters from being done and it's
at three hours and 24 minutes so yes
this is why it's taking me so long I
wanted to get it out I just needed to
have a really good reason and Halloween
slash anniversary is the perfect reason
to get the sequel out there yes so I'm
excited one of you needs to join the
rabbit
all right so our next item is a oh now
there's four people in it that's
interesting
all right there's this mysterious rabbit
has a rogue rabbit in her our next item
is an audio story submission from the
the media man show it's called ghost
house and he's narrated it and presented
it to us and we are going to listen to
it and react to it so here we go okay so
here's the story I've been compiling
information for a while and I think it's
time to start sharing what I found
nobody else is talking about this and I
need to understand what's happening
here's what I know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my uncle complain but they couldn't move
guy this pilot and they sort of became
friends and after they got out of the
hospital the pilot kept writing to my
uncle my uncle never wrote him back but
he kept all the letters and then after
my uncle died I found this whole big box
full of them it's all nonsense but it it
was weirdly consistent nonsense
how many horror stories have started
with like somebody finding an old box I
can think just off the top of my head
sinister Marble Hornets hmm the pilot
said he was part of this top-secret
program where he was put into a craft
that was meant to be moved to not just
through space but through time for just
an instance but something had gone wrong
and they'd sent him through to another
dimension like another layer of reality
they called it project iron son I think
that Kinder Surprise egg thing came from
another layer of reality
no no because he describes these things
that he saw over and over clearly they
were something wrong with the guy but my
uncle didn't Road his letters so I read
them all and I just couldn't stop
thinking about I did a bunch of
searching online but I could never find
anybody talking about any of it there
was that story the Philadelphia
Experiment but that's not real this
sounded sort of like that though
the pilot said he was placed in a
chamber and then the chamber was filled
with this light and this warm pink fluid
but somehow even when it was full he
could still breathe that's a thing
they've done with rats I've read about
it like making it so they can pull
oxygen out of the water that's a real
thing he said they were trying to travel
from our perspective of space and time
into another using a substance that
would only be referred to as negatively
charged exotic matter
they tried going smaller at first
reaching past the microcosm into a lower
condition of reality with simpler rules
than our own this pilot said that they'd
used him to pull something out of the
second dimension so it was something
with like height and width and no depth
he said it had come out screaming and
burst upon impact with our reality he
described it like a thin sheet a shadow
in his hands that suddenly turned into
an armload of black and purple guts
he said they sent him to other places
other spaces but he couldn't tell what
was real after a while they had him on a
lot of drugs to deal with the physical
and mental stress of moving through
dimensions and he said things got kind
of blurry it was that was the blurry
from the interdimensional travel or from
the drugs and further ghosts right what
kind of drugs do you take to alleviate
interdimensional travel
never tested tested this just motrin
same thing yeah a church made out of a
warm glow with billions of clockwork
pieces of Lights spinning and perfect
harmony infested with these giant wasps
that were losing a gritty oil across
everything they touched girls had a hive
up in one corner there was a broken
little bundle of excretions where they
lay their larvae and raise their broods
no only consumption and hate I feel like
I've said this on the dead stream before
but I'm getting Futurama vibes again oh
yeah there's that episode where they go
to like the space wasp nest yeah that's
a that's a creepy episode so yeah my
uncle he said the tests were done in a
concealed location he couldn't talk
about a top-secret military installation
but the people who worked there called
it the ghost house roll credits started
waving a gun around begging for somebody
to help him before he shot himself in
the head people claimed he was saying a
bunch of weird [ __ ] mumbling all crazy
to himself but there was one witness who
said that she clearly heard him say
don't send me back to the ghost house it
was just a random news story but now it
was in my head I couldn't let it go
I started doing some real research then
just searching for terms and phrases
online following paths of information
wherever they might go and that's where
I found this one live journal page this
guy with the username ace of AIDS
he describes this nightmare his hands
like being stuck in a ghost somebody
look up ace evades and see what comes at
I'm curious are people still using live
journal so I reached out to the guy and
we start emailing and eventually he
admits to me that the nightmare it's
really part of this confusing period of
time that he lost to like post-traumatic
stress disorder PTSD and he says he's
been seeing a hypnotherapist and he's on
a bunch of drugs and that he's got these
three years of his life where he's not
sure what happened he says he's not even
supposed to talk about it but he knows
he used to be a pilot okay are you
getting mad okay he says that he was
also selected to be involved in a
top-secret operation known as project
ironed Sun and eventually he did hear
people using the term I don't like the
way that he pronounced project project
yes gonna complain about that let's
comment down vote I asked him what they
were doing and he says he doesn't even
know anymore he says things got blurry
for a while and then one day he woke up
in a psych ward with an IV in his arm
and his name had been legally changed he
was no longer the man he'd been before
and in order to be released from the
psych ward he had to agree to go along
with the new life they had created for
him a new name a new identity
no family no pets he says they still
monitor him so he has to keep up the
illusion or they'll put him away again
he says he can only talk about his past
his
real past as bad dreams anything else
and they'll lock him up again
he thinks we sub people to other layers
of reality and interacted with the
things that live there he thinks we made
contact with something not aliens but
like extra dimensional beings not aliens
not ghosts but ghosts aliens and they
came back infected by whatever was on
the other side of that boundary not all
of them some were just in shock but
others carry something of that place out
inside themselves changed them he said
[Music]
these things on the other side he says
they're not what they claim to be
they're finding ways to infiltrate our
culture our society positions of social
and economic power they can look so much
like us that we revere them worship them
but they're not what they appear to be
so do these interdimensional beings
qualify to be dreamers no it's a rabbit
the like the the program of people who
moved to the US when they're very young
and I was like a controversy because the
program is ending so they're gonna get
deported Oh des they're acting like they
want to help us but that's not why
they're here you can't prove it but he
thinks they want to colonize our
dimension they want to get our whole
species primed so they can just step in
and start steering us towards a global
Holocaust a planetary concentration camp
he says they like to lay their eggs
inside our brains children's brains
especially children can take on other
dimensional concepts more when they're
laying the eggs inside of our brains are
they Kinder Surprise eggs oh my god no
very much surprise I mean I really
wouldn't mind any kind of eggs being
laid in my brain as long as it's not
that Humpty Dumpty looking ass thing too
bad it's what you get good adult brains
have a tendency to he said that it's
like a bunch of aneurysms at once
basically they burst
so I stopped getting messages from the
guy and I knew what town he lived in so
I started reading the local paper online
and quickly found evidence of a guy
named Rodney Lamarr who'd recently
thrown himself off a local bridge and
drowned the paper said he had along
history mental issues including full-on
psychotic breaks from reality and it had
most likely been during one of those
breaks that he'd chosen to end his own
line and that's that's what I got so far
I don't know what it means but that's
what I got I mean I I got a little more
but I'm gonna do a part two to this okay
and then you can use judge for yourself
what I found
Wow the saga of the ghost kinder egg
aliens
so big thank you to media man show for
submitting that if you want to find him
on soundcloud and check out the rest of
those parts if you're interested then I
will leave a link in the description
mm-hmm ladies and gentlemen it seems
that our time has come but don't worry
because we're gonna be doing new dead
streams every month and we have switched
to Saturday so our next one will be
what we haven't decided them in a date
yet halfway no not yet
all right so I just follow us on Twitter
and we will post the dates of our next
episode we're probably gonna do our
first guest next episode as well so be
on the lookout for that rabbit do you
want to fill them in on where they can
find us the best time to catch us is
live on CeCe's world channel but if you
miss it
we're also on YouTube iTunes and Google
Play if you have a story that you'd like
us to read here on the show or if you
find about find out about any news going
on in the YouTube horror community that
we might want to talk about send an
email to Susie's worth at gmail.com the
music in the dead stream is composed by
the incredible Louis tea makers so if
they're already music fans out there
look out for his link in the description
and subscribe to her steam maker because
he's amazing
rabbit where can people find you on
social media you can find me on Facebook
and Twitter if you search Lady white
rabbit and now I am also on soundcloud
[Music]
and Mort how can the fans connect with
you on the internet you can find me on
Instagram and Twitter
kiss media you can find me on Facebook
Google+ and Instagram and C's world my
twitter handle is C Z's world underscore
horror remember to subscribe to seize
his world for new Horrors every week
there's actually gonna be a new video
going up tomorrow and new things you
missed on the horror movie mother and
then the day after that I'm doing a
collab with don't turn around
so busy weekend for me ring that death
bell for notifications so you don't miss
anything
and we will see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you